-Now, Major League Baseball
just started.
And in honor of that,
Tariq and I had
a friendly competition
of our own.
Look at how friendly he is.
[ Light laughter ]
To see who can make
the best baseball-themed cake.
-Oh.
It's the first annual
"Tonight Show Cake-Off."
Now, the rules are simple --
you have 30 minutes
to decorate your cake
in the baseball theme
of your choosing,
but no references to teams from
New York or Philadelphia, okay?
Higgins will judge
who made the best cake
and declare one of us
the Cake-Off Champion.
[ Audience cheers ]
Well, earlier today,
Tariq and I made our cakes,
and we recorded the whole thing,
which we're about to show you.
But first, to ensure that it's
a fair and unbiased contest,
Higgins, please leave the studio
and head to the isolation room.
-I shall head
to the isolation room.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, Higgins, be careful.
-Ooh!
[ Light jazz music plays ]
-There you go.
That's the isolation room.
Now, Higgins, please put on
the dome of silence.
-The dome of silence.
[ Light laughter ]
-Perfect. All right.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Here --
[ Light laughter ]
Here's Tariq and I
earlier today, making our cakes.
Check it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, I'm Jimmy Fallon,
and this is
my baseball-themed cake.
I am going to make the head
of one of my favorite
third basemen of all time,
Brooks Robinson.
And I was actually lucky enough
to meet him as a kid --
I was probably 8 or 9.
He was nice enough
to even take a photo with me.
I always loved him.
-The champ is here.
I decided to do a carrot cake.
The brown is sort of comparable
to the soil of the field.
[ Chuckles ]
-Tariq doesn't even
watch baseball.
I don't think Tariq
watches sports.
-I like baseball.
I like it enough.
I don't love it.
I love cake.
-This should be
a home run for me.
Pun intended.
Alright,
so what you're gonna do is --
this is a seven-layer cake.
So, the first layer goes on.
Then you want
to put buttercream on.
-I like to do a cream-cheese
icing with a little carrot top.
Try and get it as seamless
as possible.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
-Now, as I'm going,
you can kind of see already
the shape of the head.
Cake and baseball --
it's like, you know --
The original lyrics of
"Take Me Out to the Ball Game"
was like...
♪ Buy me some cake ♪
-This is my first time
ever hearing cake and baseball
in the same sentence.
I feel like this is a setup.
Like, "Here's the competition --
we're gonna do, you know,
spaghetti and tennis."
It's [bleep] stupid.
It's stupid.
[ Laughter ]
-It almost looks
exactly like him already.
Tariq, you're going down, buddy.
-We can take, like,
a candy popcorn ball,
and we can cover it
in the fondant
and make it look
like a baseball.
-You want to get
some eye holes in there.
[ Light laughter ]
Stick it in the eye hole.
It's almost like he's cocking
his head to the side,
kind of thinking, like,
"Should I catch this one?"
Now you start applying the skin
so people think
they are looking at a --
well, a human head.
Just to even own
"The Tonight Show"
Championship Bake-Off
golden cake pan would be enough.
But to have my name
engraved in it?
That's the icing on the cake.
-To get my name engraved,
it would mean
absolutely nothing to me.
[ Laughter ]
-I had our great Art Department
help me with the hat.
You throw a couple skewers
in there
to help stabilize the hat.
-Oh!
-It's all good.
It's all good.
[ Light laughter ]
Oh, no. Ohh, God.
Kind of a disaster.
All right. Hold on.
[ Chuckles ]
It's fixable.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Ah! Don't -- Don't give up.
Don't give up.
It's all savable.
-And then, you know,
you can go in
and do some baseball-y
sort of details,
make it look more realistic.
-So, now that
you got the brim on...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
So, let's stick a nose on there.
[ Laughter ]
Get the eyes, of course.
You can kind of see it already.
It's all fixable,
and we can clear it up.
How confident am I
or how "con-fondant" am I
that Higgins
will choose my cake?
He knows Brooks -- he'll take
one look at the cake and go,
"That's the greatest
third baseman
in the history of the sport."
If not, then he's out!
-If he's judging on just,
you know,
the most magnificent idea,
then it's already in the bag.
-If I mush -- If I mess around
with the photo a little bit,
you can kind of see
where it's going.
Brooks Robinson.
-It's going to be spectacular.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Dude, it's a disaster.
It's a total disaster!
Dude, it was looking so good.
It happened so fast.
It happened
in like three seconds.
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh."
-Yup.
-I got to really sell --
I got to really sell Higgins
on this one.
[ Laughter ]
This -- It --
[ Clears throat ]
Alright. Here we go.
Tough competition.
[ Laughter ]
Higgins may now exit
the isolation room.
I got to have a poker face.
[ Breathes sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
Alright.
They poked him...
And now he can take his place
at the judge's table.
Higgins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There he is, Steve Higgins,
ladies and gentlemen.
Looking good, bud. Good.
Yeah, this is good.
Now, Higgins, it is now time
to try the cakes.
So, whenever you're ready,
please try cake number one.
-Number one.
-Yes.
-Ooh, beautiful!
-Uh-huh. Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-Wow!
Looks like a baseball on top.
-Yep.
-Carrot cake, it looks like.
There we go. Mmm.
-Nice slice.
-Okay. Mmm, mmm!
Mmm!
♪♪
-Wow.
-Mmm!
Mmm.
I'm sensing carrots.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, well, it's carrot cake.
Yes, of course.
-And cake.
-Now Higgins, try...
-Very good.
Moist, delicious.
-...cake number two.
-Cake number two.
-Yeah, there we go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
There it is.
[ Laughter ]
Cake number two.
-Is that a human ear?
-That is -- What?
-Oh, my God.
-[ Laughing ] I have no idea.
-Did the cake drop?
-What are you talking about?
-Mmm. No, looks delicious.
-Can you guess --
Can you guess who that is?
-I'm going to say it's a player
who died in a horrible accident.
[ Laughter ]
-The famous -- Right?
-It's the famous player
from the -- from the --
what -- Baltimore --
is that?
-That's correct.
-Orioles?
-Sure.
-Okay, let me try.
[ Laughs ] Where do --
Where do I even begin
with this deliciousness?
-That's exactly right.
-I'm going to say it's
a yellow cake -- I'm guessing.
-Yup, that's the fun thing
about this cake.
Everyone can cut it
from all angles.
-You know what? Yeah.
And the person becomes
co-author of the cake.
-You can --
You can remove the hat, too,
if you want,
and slice down the middle.
-Oh, let me see
what's underneath there.
Is it a human brain?
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a brain.
It's not a brain.
You can just slice
down the middle.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckling ]
-Just get yourself a good slice.
-I got --
-Wait a second.
There's a spoon in here!
-Yeah, I was --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I -- Well, you got to make sure
the -- the head was ---
you got to make sure
the head's sturdy.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
-Seriously --
But th--
Watch out for the skewers.
-Yeah, there's a lot of --
-Watch out for the --
There's a little --
Watch out for the skewers.
-It's like a sauté cake.
-They are not edible.
The skewers are not edible.
-Yeah, they're not edible.
-No.
-They are scaffolding.
-Yeah, to hold it up.
Alright, I'm gonna taste a...
-All right, here we go.
-...delicious piece of this --
what I'm going to call "cake."
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, that is -- There you go.
-Okay.
-Yep.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I feel like --
-Mmm!
-I feel like it's rigged.
-[ Laughing ] So good!
Wait, I've got
to make sure the hat --
-Put the hat back on.
-Beautiful. My God.
That's like -- that's like
a Cake Boss made this one.
-Yeah. That was a --
[ Laughter ]
-That's not fair. I mean, you
had a professional who --
That's that guy I love.
-Brooks Robinson.
-Brooks --
[ Laughter ]
The world-famous
Brooks Robinson,
my favorite player...
-That's right.
-...from
the Baltimore Orioles...
-Yep.
-...who played --
-It could also be -- It could be
Cal Ripken, if you want.
-Sure.
-But, no, that's --
I mean, that's not even funny.
-Oh, my God. That's beautiful.
-Alright.
Well, anyways, Higgins,
it's time for your vote.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Laughter ]
Please -- Please write down your
choice for the winning cake...
-Okay, I'm writing down
my choices,
putting it in the...
-...and put it into the official
"Tonight Show Cake-Off"
ballot box.
-...super secret ballot box.
-Will it be cake number one
or cake number two?
♪♪
-Okay, ready?
I got to unlock it.
-The vote is locked in.
-[ Chuckling ] I got to --
I got to unlock it.
-Alright.
There you go. Yeah.
I don't know why we have a pad--
Why do we have padlock on there?
-Ready?
[ Drum roll ]
-Here we go.
-The winner is...
-Higgins, the winner is...
-...cake number one.
-Ah!
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell ringing ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Who made --
-Congratulations.
-Wait, but who made each --
Who made the --
I don't know who made each cake.
-Tariq.
Congratulations to
"The Tonight Show Cake-Off"
winner,
Tariq Trotter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq Trotter, everybody!
-Alright!
-Congratulations.
-I just want to --
I just want to say to
every root vegetable,
you know, who's been told
to just jump into the juicer
that you, too, can exist
in a Black Thought cake!
I mean, I'm talking --
Come on, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations
to "The Tonight Show Cake-Off"
champion, Tariq Trotter.
-And radishes, beets!
Stick around
for more "Tonight Show,"
everybody!
-Parsnips!
-Brooks, I'm sorry. I tried.
-We won!
Philly! We're taking it
back to Philly, baby!
Yes, sir! Yes, sir!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪